يعترف الاوكرانيون ان الهجوم المضاده يمر
في ظروف صعبه وانهم يحققون تقدما بطيئا
الرئيس الاوكراني قال ان الاسبوع الماضي
كان صعبا على الجبهه لكن قواته تتقدم خطوه
بخطوه اما نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
غانم مليار فقد قالت ان القوات الاوكرانيه
استعادت خلال اسبوع 37 كيلومترا على
الجبهتين الشرقيه والجنوبيه واوضحت ان
مجمل الاراضي التي استرجعت منذ بدء الهجوم
المضاد في مطلعي يونيو بلغت 158 كيلومترا
قبل بدء هذا الهجوم كان سقف التطلعات
عاليا جدا لكن الامور لم تمضي كما كان
متوقعا القائد العام للقوات الاوكرانيه
فاليريزالونجي قال ان انتقادات بعض
الاطراف الغربيه لبطء الهجوم المضاد يثير
استياءه واضاف ان قواته مقيده في الهجوم
بسبب التاخر في تسليم الاسلحه الغربيه
ونقص الاسلحه وخاصه الطائرات المقاتله
رئيس اللجنه العسكريه في النيتو والاميرال
روب باور حاولت تخفيفا من حده ما بدا انه
خلاف بين اوكرانيا وحلفائها الغربيين وقال
ان الهجوم المضاد امر صعب وانه لا يجب ان
يظن البعض بتاتا انها عمليه سهله لان هناك
عددا كبيرا من الروس في اوكرانيا ولان
العراقيل الدفاعيه ضخمه لا تكتفي روسيا
بالدفاع بل انها باعتراف الاوكرانيين
تهاجم بالقرب من
وماريانكا ولمان هذا الوضع في الميدان بدت
اثاره واضحه في تصريحات وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجي شويجو الذي قال ان كيف لم
تحقق اهدافها على اي محور منذ بدء الهجوم
المضاد وفي اول تعليق له على تمرد فاغنر
قال شويغو ان التمرد لم يؤثر على عمليات
القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا واشاد بولاء
الجنود
قال انه سمح بافشال التمرد لكن الحرب لا
تقتصر على الاراضي الاوكرانيه تتعرض
مقاطعه بيلو جرود الروسيه الحدوديه لهجمات
ايضا حاكم المقاطعه قال ان القوات
الاوكرانيه اطلقت 140 قذيفه على مناطق في
المقاطعه خلال 24 ساعه يبدو من خلال
تطورات الميدانيه الحاليه انه بقدر ما
اعدت كييف لهجومها المضاد استعدت روسيا
للدفاع عن الاراضي التي سيطرت عليها ويبدو
ان زمن الانتصارات الخاطفه في هذه الحرب
قد ولى